another reading from Star
Messenger Cosmic perspectives on
civilization we can expect to Live Twice
As long today as people in the year
1900 walk the rows of any old cemetery
and do the math the chiseled birth and
death rates on each Tombstone bear
Silent Witness to the shortened life
expectancies of bygone eras you'll be
glad you live today and not any time in
the past but in one or hundred years
will those who tore the cemeteries that
contain all our remains think the same
of us as they pity our poultry 80-year
life
expectancies will they be the ones who
live long enough to travel among the
distant planets and the Stars
themselves suppose we could live forever
it's better to be alive than dead though
more often than not we take being alive
for granted the question remains if you
could live
forever would you to live forever is to
have all the time in the world to do
anything you ever wanted you could even
Mutiny a Generation Starship and return
home to Earth if you wanted
to seems like an attractive idea but
maybe the knowledge of death creates the
focus that we bring to being
alive if you live forever then what's
the
hurry why do today what you can put off
until
tomorrow there is perhaps no greater
demotivating force than the knowledge
you will live
forever if true then knowledge of your
mortality may also be a force unto
itself the urge to achieve and the need
to express love and affection now not
later mathematically if death gives
meaning to life then to live forever is
to live a life with no meaning at
all for these reasons death may be more
important to our state of mind than we
are willing to
recognize if you were to bring a
colorful bouquet of flowers to a loved
one and those flowers were made of
plastic or even silk they would surely
be less appreciated than if they were
real flowers that live forever miss the
point we seek the increasing beauty of
each flower in a bouquet as they unfurl
one by one in the light of day we're
absorbed by their irresistible Aromas we
duly accept the care and feeding they
require we Embrace their sence as the
stems weaken no longer sustaining the
weight of the faded
petals florists remain in business
because the death of flowers typically
within a week of receiving them is
precisely what gives them meaning to
your loved one compare that with Forever
Flowers that require no maintenance
never d ey have no smell yet remain just
as beautiful a week a month a year
later dogs aren't flowers but they
convey a similar story ever notice how
enthusiastic they can be if you let them
dogs will jump all over you and lick
your face they'll Chase and retrieve
things you throw they're ecstatic when
you return home even if you just went
out to the mailbox and came right
back they love every minute you spend
with them for most dogs each day
matters humans live approximately seven
times longer than dogs that's the origin
of the famous dog years
calculation multiply your dog's actual
age by seven and you get an equivalent
age for a
human keeping with the 7:1 ratio
a day unto a dog is a week unto
humans maybe that's why they make
everyday
count like flowers on the mantle not a
day goes by when they do not compel you
to take notice and
smile if your family brought home a
puppy dog during your childhood years
you saw it grow and eventually get old
and die while you were either in high
school or college
and surely remember those
years not everything dies for having
grown
old contrary to the collective delusion
that mother nature is a nurturing caring
entity that cradles and protects all its
forms of life Earth is
instead a giant killing
machine holding aside all the climactic
and geologic forces that would just as
soon have you dead such as droughts
floods hurricanes tornadoes earthquakes
tsunamis and
volcanoes there's no end of creatures
that want to suck your blood inject you
with Venom infect your
physiology or simply eat you the
universe wants to kill you
too at least one of the six Extinction
episodes in Earth's timeline of light
the Cretaceous tertiary event from 66
million years ago was partly or entirely
triggered by the impact of a rogue
asteroid the size of Mount
Everest with no space program at the
time to deflect the impactor it was a
bad day for the
dinosaurs was also a bad day for 70% of
all species on land and in the oceans
they too went extinct and if you think
that was bad during the so-called peran
Triassic Extinction of 250 million years
ago life on earth almost ended
entirely modern humans are complicit in
Mother Nature's wrath our encroachment
on pristine ecosystems is rendering
species extinct at a rate up to a, times
the ongoing level that it naturally
occurs geologists have named a stretch
of time to identify our upheaval of
Earth's
biosphere from the dawn of Agriculture
11,700 years ago through today they call
it the hollene
Epic of all species that ever lived on
earth
99.9% of them have gone
extinct who knows what wonders of
biodiversity died out of the world for
want of the lack of the strength or the
will to
[Music]
survive